venecia ha sido reconocida durante mucho
tiempo como una de las atracciones
turísticas más apetecidas de europa
miles de visitantes exploran los canales
de la ciudad cada día antes de acudir en
masa a la emblemática plaza de san
marcos sin embargo a menudo se ven pasar
gigantescos cruceros interrumpiendo la
vista de los espectadores activistas y
residentes han buscado durante muchos
años que se prohíban los barcos dicen
que causan grandes olas que socavan los
cimientos de la ciudad y afectan el
frágil ecosistema de su laguna en medio
del retorno de los turistas después de
la pandemia la unesco recomendó el mes
pasado e incluir a venecia en la lista
de lugares de patrimonio mundial en
peligro y tras una revisión de las
condiciones de la ciudad el gobierno de
italia decidió el martes introducir
formalmente la prohibición declarando
las vías navegables de venecia como
monumento nacional negra decisión que es
una decisión importante habrá
compensación para aquellos que sufren
daños económicos como consecuencia de
esta iniciativa pero italia finalmente
está cambiando de página la prohibición
comenzará el primero de agosto y se
aplicará a los buques que pesen más
25.000 toneladas o me dan más de 180
metros aunque los cruceros que
transporten a 200 personas o menos
todavía serán permitidos en el centro de
la ciudad